after years of waiting starfield finally
received a cinematic trailer
and while we were all hoping to see some
gameplay by this point personally i'd
rather give developers the time they
need to make the best work possible
but we still did get something so let's
see what we can find
to start what do we know so far about
starfield
we know it will be a role-playing game
where as todd howard says
you can be who you want so while it's
unclear how strong the narrative focus
of the game will be as of yet
or if side quests or the main story will
be more of the motivating factor
it's likely the game will have a similar
character builder and customization to
the elder scrolls and fallout games
you'll be a blank slate and likely able
to affect the universe around you by
your choices
this is a brand new universe being
crafted by bethesda
so while there may be some references to
fallout or elder scrolls
and share some of their mechanics this
is its own world and story
according to todd howard constellation
is the last
group of space explorers does that mean
that space is so explored by this point
it's not a very sought after profession
or is it such a dangerous profession and
very few people choose to do it
or maybe it's more political a la mass
effect where exploring the universe
could mean finding
horrifying new civilizations that could
wipe out everything we know
well we don't know what we do know
is that there's concept art of multiple
worlds being shown
with different terrain whether this be a
metropolis
an alien jungle or a city built over a
vast stretch of water
and thanks to this concept art we also
get a glimpse of some of the aliens
the ones shown here are more crab-like
and seem well-suited for their
environment
while i'm sure various races will have
the technology to travel to different
worlds
hopefully that means the local creatures
on each planet will be specific to that
planet and its terrain
and speaking of different terrain we
were also shown concept art for various
outfits the character can wear depending
on what type of environment they'll be
in
again it's hard to say if wearing the
proper gear will be a requirement for
traversing certain terrains
or if this will be more aesthetic but it
draws the question
finally before digging into the trailer
itself in bethesda's behind the scenes
video of starfield
we can see someone typing away at a
document so
what does it say and does it reveal
anything
well enhance enhance
enhance okay that's actually pretty
blurry
so here's what it says united colonies
logo at the top
svs def logo below it to the left uv
vanguard below it to the right
urgent communique please be on alert
pirates of the crimson fleet have
extended far beyond the crick system
and have established footholds in the
saigon cheyenne
lunara and narion systems both sis death
and the vanguard
are committed to ridding united colonies
space of these parasites
this is clearly no longer just a free
star collective problem
also be advised that the crimson fleet
is not a single organized entity or
faction
rather it's a loose confederation of
individual captains
all organized under the same banner
shown here is the symbol or
jolly roger they've adopted anyone
displaying that symbol
is assumed to be associated with the
crimson fleet and can be terminated
at will crimson fleet logo here any
question should be addressed to the
lieutenant
john twala at mast for the vanguard and
commander kibwe
ikande aboard the uc vigilance persist
death
uc fleet admiral pasquel logan mast
military administrative and scientific
triumvirate
new atlantis planet jemisin alpha
centauri
so where does this little drop of the
story leave us i
imagine that similar to elder scrolls
and fallout the pirates of the crimson
fleet are a faction that you choose to
fight against
join or do some sort of missions for and
the same goes for mast who would seem to
be the general government in charge of
the united colonies
this is pure speculation right now but i
do wonder if new atlantis is this
particular bit of concept art we saw in
the trailer
with the city over vast sea so a bunch
of what we do know is thanks to this
bethesda presentation video
and taking all of that let's see what we
can gather from the cinematic trailer
the trailer begins noting that the
starship frontier ng
1350 is a part of the constellation and
thus a vehicle meant for space
exploration
next we see an astronaut entering the
starship from inside
on the left-hand side of the ship is a
small but clear medical station
i think it's safe to gather from this
that the starship will likely serve as a
resting point for your character
similar to a home in fallout or elder
scrolls it's probably a safe place to
return to where you can always heal
up our pilot climbs aboard the ship and
inside are a number of tables with
interesting items on them
these include a flight manual and mug
for nova galactic
while we have no idea exactly how the
rpg mechanics will work in starfield
the flight manual does somewhat resemble
the books for leveling up your skills
and fallout
we see a couple books omega and sailing
all around the world written by captain
joshua stokem
the constellation space fares guide a
broken helmet
and a unique constellation box the box
says
lifepak interlink on it and a physical
version of the box was even built and
shown in bethesda's behind the scenes
video
in that video we see the box contains a
watch and a badge with constellations
logo on it
while those may just be some sort of
pre-order bonuses
or a starfield inspired merch watch we
can at least gather a year from this
establish 2188 i have a feeling this is
in reference to constellation itself and
constellation began exploring the galaxy
in 2188
in game for all we know these boxes
could simply be what are used to store
goodies you'll find
but we'll eventually find out on the
side of the first table which has a
number of items on it it's a little hard
to read the display
especially with the glare on it the top
left looks like it says astral guidance
reference
and there's an eta of minus oo2203
this station could be in-game where you
choose your destinations to fly to
before moving on i do of course need to
note the gun that the pilot sets down on
the table
for some reason a warning logo is
flashing on the gun and it's displaying
that it has 24 ammo left
i have absolutely no idea if a gameplay
mechanic similar to fallout's vats will
be in game
but i have to imagine there will be more
to the gameplay than only fps mechanics
as of yet it's unclear what the flashing
warning sign is but perhaps it means
some sort of weapon degradation system
the other item on the table next to the
gun looks like some kind of grenade
or if we're dreaming here almost looks
like a lightsaber
the middle portion looks like a grip so
it's clearly meant to be held
we then see plenty of notes written on
the inside window the top says
best settings for the engine ship and
arv
whatever that is below says upgrade
reactor
p remember sidonia security does not
have a sense of humor and finally vasco
we're out of tranquility a do not get
decaf
this is the first time we've seen
sedonia mentioned but i'm guessing
that's either a city or world in the
game
meanwhile tranquility a would seem to be
the game's coffee variation of nuka-cola
on the wall are several photos of a mech
from a third person perspective
my guess is that those are actual
screenshots of gameplay
we see mechs in the trailer and i have a
feeling that you'll not only be able to
control them
but when you do you enter this third
person perspective
the pilot is also a fan of the violent
sounds of alyssa demille
uh something clearly your pilot is a man
of class also tapes of the wall are
schematics
while i can't make out what most of it
says one note states
we have so far been unable to determine
what happens in the reactor
there are many theories i've seen online
speculating that this could create a
wormhole of some sort
or some other system of fast travel a
glimpse of the outside world shows what
looks to be a moonlike environment
some kind of station nearby and as i
mentioned before
a mech the met climbs aboard the ship is
this the playable character
or are you the pilot alternatively could
this mech be a companion with
personality
it's difficult to say but perhaps you
won't be alone when traversing on the
frontier
now let's travel into the cockpit
gravity power and life systems are shown
as a part of this
which makes me wonder if you can
actually upgrade your starship and this
is a part of that
on another display in the cockpit we can
see weapons shields and a boost function
this would indicate that there will be
space battles on top of traversing the
various planets
that said piloting the ship hasn't been
confirmed and i could be reading too
much into this
finally the release date is shown
november 11
2022 and that's everything i was able to
break down from the starfield trailer
let me know if there's anything you
noticed that i missed if you enjoyed
this
consider watching our breakdowns for
elder ring or breath of the wild 2.
we're also streaming as a part of play
for all where we're raising money for
ablegamers charity
if that interests you please consider
giving it a watch and i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you